>>Male Presenter: So good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to another outstanding Authors at
Google talk. Today, we're very pleased to
introduce Jenny Blake. Jenny Blake is an author,
blogger, life coach, Googler, and yoga teacher.
Her book, "Life after College: The Complete
Guide to Getting What You Want," compiles
learning advice in bite-size nuggets for every
area of someone's life, and is based on her
popular blog, lifeaftercollege.org.
She has also worked at Google for over five
years and currently serves as a Career Development
Program Manager, an internal coach and also
helps with us here on the Authors at Google
team. Throughout her life, she is guided by
philosophies to help others feel excited and
happy about their own lives.
Jenny's book offers practical advice to the
post-college crowd. After reading the book
myself, I was particularly struck by a certain
quote, which I'll include here. "Life after
college is still about learning, learning
who you are, what you want, how to get it,
and perhaps most importantly, how to relax
and enjoy the ride."
Jenny's learning’s also continue as she
starts her three-month sabbatical and her
book tour, as you can see now, is making a
stop here at Google. As per our tradition,
we'll have some time for question and answer
at the end. And without further ado, let me
introduce Jenny Blake.
[applause]
>>Jenny Blake: Thank you, Kurt.
>>Male Presenter: Oh, you can-
>>Jenny Blake: Yeah. Woohoo. So excited to
be here. Thank you all so much for coming.
I'm not sure, but I think this is the first
Googler speaking as an author at Google. So
thank you all for coming and for being here.
I've been on sabbatical now for three weeks
and you will be proud to know that I've successfully
learned how to feed myself out in the wild.
[laughter]
Thank you. I didn't say anything about cooking.
I toast and I microwave, but that's a start.
Life does go on, even outside of these glorious
three meals a day. I thought about what might
be fun to talk about today. And I figure you're
all Googlers. I think you got life after college
pretty figured out. You're doing great.
So I wanted to share some of my tips and lessons
learned from the publishing process, itself.
I've been amazed at how many people say to
me when I tell them I've written a book, "That's
amazing. I've love to write a book someday."
And as I often do on my blog, I take tips
and lessons from life experiences, whether
it's river rafting or now, in this case, publishing
a book.
[pause]
Before I jump into my ten lessons learned,
I'll just give you the super quick version
of how I got my book deal.
At the end of 2008, I'd been blogging for
about a year, and I started writing a book.
I had an idea. I was on the Training and Development
team at the time. So Steve, Kevin, Ian, you
guys remember we went away for the Christmas
holidays, 2008, I came back and our team meeting
we said, "What's your 2009 resolution?"
And I said, "To finish and publish my book."
And I was so happy, I was on a roll, I got
the first draft out there, I was stoked; so
excited. And then came this. My hair pulling,
frustrated, complete and utter book block.
I had been on a roll and I told myself, "I'm
gonna self-publish. Who needs to bother with
the whole traditional publishing route? I
got this. I'll self-publish. It'll be great.
I'll get the book out there." Really, I knew
that I was saying that because I was terrified.
I was scared, too. I had no idea how to go
about getting a traditional publisher, how
to find a literary agent.
And then even if I did, I was so afraid of
rejection. And I was afraid that after all
this work of writing my book and getting the
draft done, that I would show it to these
publishing houses and they would say it was
the worst thing they'd ever seen and, "Go
away. Go home, you amateur."
That didn't end up happening. But that fear
was paralyzing for me.
[pause]
Finally, in a very serendipitous meeting that
I'll explain in a little bit, I got motivated
to not finish my book, but I decided I've
gotta at least try.
I would so much rather be on the field playing
the game than in the stands, watching. And
just like out of high school, I had applied
to Harvard because I wanted to at least try.
So it was a shot in the dark. I knew I probably
wouldn't get in. But I would know that I applied
and I gave myself the chance. I didn't get
in, by the way.
Go, Bruins. UCLA for the win. Woohoo. So in
this case, I decided I've gotta try. And the
first step was writing a book proposal. I
still couldn't bring myself to open the Word
file with my book. It sat closed for six months.
But I could do a book proposal. And that's
basically a 35-page business plan. From the
book proposal, I found a literary agent.
She didn't look quite like this with those
big 80s earrings, but close. And my literary
agent pitched to publishing houses. Some,
they were interested. I had a meeting at Random
House, very exciting. It was on the 18th floor
of this building overlooking Central Park.
Truly, an amazing moment being in a room with
all these executives asking me questions.
It was crazy. It was fun. Chronicle Books
in San Francisco was also interested. They
were gonna make it a really nice gift book.
And then there was Running Press. In the end,
my agent pitched to 27 publishers. Actually,
it was 28 publishers. Twenty seven said no,
and one said yes. One's all it takes.
So, Running Press agreed to publish my book
and I signed the contract on June 16th of
2010. So it's been a long road. It's been
two and a half years. When I wrote that first
draft in 2008, I was sure that my book would
be out by graduation 2009. Well, it's March
2011, so a couple years have passed. You can
see a few things happened in-between. And
that's what I want to talk about today. All
those highs and lows and what I learned in
the process.
It wouldn't be a Jenny Blake presentation
if there wasn't a gratuitous cupcake picture.
That's really why I put this slide in here.
[laughter]
Ten. Don't wait for permission. So often,
people are waiting for someone to wave their
magic wand and say, I hereby grant you the
permission to start that project that you've
been wanting to do. To go take those classes
you've been wanting to take. To start writing
the book. To start your blog. To do whatever
it is. Run a marathon.
Whatever it is that you wanna do, don't wait
for permission. You would be so surprised
at how much you're capable of if you give
yourself the chance to try. And on that same
note, take your inner critic, those voices
that say you're not good enough, you're not
smart enough, you're too old, you're too young,
as a sign that you're exactly on the right
track.
It's hard to do, because they can be debilitating.
And I know that. That's why my book sat unopened
for six months. But the fact that they're
there, means that you're on exactly the right
track. You're doing big things. You're getting
ready to take a big risk. And that's exactly
when all those voices come rushing in and
it's a great thing.
In my case, there were, when I Googled, yes
Googled on Amazon, there were 20 other books
with "Life After College" in the title, twenty.
Who was I to think that I had anything to
add to this already oversaturated genre? And
I thought I'm simultaneously too old. At the
time I was like, 25, too young and I've never
lived in Africa or done anything really crazy,
out of the ordinary.
And I just thought, "Who am I to write this
book?" And then one day, one of my friends,
she's a blogger. She said to me, "Jenny, this
book may have been written, but it hasn't
been written by you." And that gave me the
motivation to say, "Great. If I help two people,
if I help one person, then it's worth it.
And I'm gonna enjoy the process."
Number Nine. Trust your gut. With a big creative
project, the only way to do it is through
your intuition. And you can see here, there's
a couple different routes to take. There will
not be any prescribed route that details exactly
how to go. So, you've gotta listen to your
gut and just take some chances.
You'll know. In my case, when my gut was telling
me when I had book block for six months, I
can be a little thick-headed sometimes, so
finally after six months, I realized, "Oh,
it's because I'm not supposed to self-publish."
And I was thankful to come to that realization,
even though it took me a little while. And
I'm learning; it's still a learning process
for me and probably for all of you, to keep
trusting my gut and to learn to listen to
it more every day.
OK. On this note, when the universe smacks
you upside the head, listen. As I said, sometimes
I can be kinda dense, all right?
[laughter]
I'm sure we all can. When I couldn't look
at my book and that was a horrible feeling.
I felt like I was watching my dream die on
the vine because I couldn't muster the strength
to actually do something about it. And I just
felt horrible.
So I decided, "Well, if I can't continue on
my path of being an author right now, I'll
at least act as if, I'll pretend I'm a professional
speaker." So I went to this Northern California
Speakers Association meeting. And while I
was there, I met the author of the book, "How
to Write a Book Proposal," Michael Larson.
I sat at the same table with him at lunch
and he ended up giving me his copy of "How
to Write a Book Proposal." So if that's not
a sign from the universe to get back on the
horse and get out there, I don't know what
is. And the fact that he said he'd be willing
to review my proposal with me that was all
the push I needed to get back out there and
keep going.
And what I call one of my "universe smacks
me upside the head" moments. Like, "You idiot,
get back out there." And I did and I'm so
thankful.
Number Eight. I heard this first from a coach
a couple years ago. Avoid the tyranny of the
how’s. You will not see the whole path.
It is absolutely inherent to a big goal or
a big project, even working at a company like
Google, you will not see the whole path of
how you're gonna get to the end result.
At best, you might see a couple steps in front
of you. Certainly having the vision for what
you want, the desired outcome is important,
but don't feel like you have to see the whole
path, step by step, just in order to get started.
Oftentimes, I work with a lot of coaching
clients and I see this a lot on my blog, people
who are so worried about how they're gonna
do something that they never start.
And document; it's totally fine to worry about
how you're gonna do something, but don't let
that hold you back. And don't let that fear
and those gears churning, paralyze you from
taking action. I always recommend people make
a list. What are all the how’s that you
don't know right now?
And if you can at least frame them as questions,
the answers will come, but don't feel like
you have to have them all upfront. As my dad
recently said to me, "You probably don't even
wanna see the whole path." He said, "If someone
had told you two and a half years ago what
you would have to go through and how much
work it would take to get this book out, you'd
have been pretty scared."
And that is absolutely true. I would have
been completely intimidated by the amount
of work it was gonna take and commitment and
drive and the emotional ups and downs and
the fear of putting my ideas out there for
judgment. It's a lot. And so, maybe we take
this as a good thing that we don't know how
it's all gonna work.
This is one of my favorite slides. Fight for
what you believe in. Trust your instincts.
I was really lucky. Running Press gave me
a ton of freedom with the content of the book.
They really let the book be my own. The biggest
piece of feedback they had was when I turned
in a 450-page draft, and they said, "No way,
get this down to 300. I don't care how you
do it. I don't care what you cut. Three hundred
or less. Then it came time to working with
the cover.
[laughter]
You know where this is going, right? OK, good.
Authors don't have final say over the cover
of their book. They don't have final approval.
In the contract, it says you get "meaningful
input." OK, yes. Everyone interprets this
differently. And in my case, we'd been looking
at concepts for the cover, but I hadn't really
seen much.
And then all of a sudden, one day they sent
me a cover and said, "Here's your cover and
we sent the book to press. It's shipped."
I was not pleased with this cover to put it
lightly. And I handled it really maturely,
as any mature, grown adult would by hysterically
crying for three days straight, three.
Hysterical, I call them projectile tears,
flying off my face at every moment. Here I
was, I'd been working so hard for two and
a half years, and then all of a sudden, my
project, my baby, that I had been slaving
over was wrapped up in this bow that I, to
be honest, was embarrassed by. And I didn't
know what to do so I was ready to give up.
I wrote back. I said, "I'm not happy with
this. Let me outline the reasons why." And
it was too late. They had already sent it.
And that was on a Friday. On Sunday, I went
for a walk with my dad. I've never been so
sad. We go for these weekly walks with our
dog, talk about life. We talked about the
book at every single step.
And he said, "Jenny, this is not when you
lay down and give up. You are at the very
end of this project. You get up and fight.
You don't just lay down. This is the time
you have got to do something. Get your lawyer
on the phone. Talk to your agent." My dad
went crazy. And at the time, as any kid reacts
to their parent, I was like, "Dad, come on.
Give it a break. I give up. It's over." I
was bumed.
But when I got home, I said, "He's right.
I've gotta do something. I have to keep fighting."
I thought I had put in a fight. I didn't.
I emailed my literary agent and thankfully,
she emailed the publisher and they revised
the cover a couple days later. I've never
been so nervous to open an email 'cause I
knew that the next cover that came in was
gonna have to be it, 'cause we were already
gonna be behind schedule.
So, without further ado, I'll show you before.
A little chaotic and I wasn't thrilled with
the dead pig on the bottom, or the phone that
already looked ten years old. I mean, hello.
Android, iPhone, give me something to work
with here.
[laughter]
OK. So that was the old one and then here
is the new cover, which we're all so happy
with. And I'm so grateful that Running Press
said, "We don't want to have an author who's
embarrassed by their book, either. That's
not good for us." So thankfully, they worked
with me and I took this as a sign.
The process was so smooth up to this point.
I needed something big like this, so I had
a great book publishing story to tell and
it was a reminder to fight for what you believe
in.
Number six. Build and lean on your support
network. It absolutely has taken an army to
get this project out there to the world. Yes,
there have been many nights and many weekends
where I've been holed up in my apartment working
on my laptop in my condo on the balcony. But
it takes an army.
And there were so many times that I was down
and discouraged. And my mom, my dad, friends
like Tara and Julie, who were there to pick
me up when I was down and say, "How can I
help? How can we celebrate? What can I do?"
So I really encourage you to lean on your
support network.
Ask for help. People want to help. And the
same is true at a company like Google. We
have so many people, brilliant minds in one
place. Lean on your network. Reach out to
people you don't know. I've been absolutely
blown away and humbled by the response on
the internet this week.
And on the first day, the book actually shot
up to number eleven in Career Guides because
of my support network. And I'm as proud of
that as I am the book itself.
Number five. Recognize and appreciate the
beauty in imperfection. What you see here
is a picture and I brought the live copy.
All those yellow post-its are typos that I
found.
[laughter]
And yes, my friends will be the first to tell
you that I'm a recovering perfectionist and
not recovering very quickly. But I care. I'm
a perfectionist because I care. So when I
saw these typos, sure, I could've gotten really
discouraged and really upset. But as my dad
says, "That's how all the demons get out."
So it's actually a good sign and it happens.
I used to read books and say, "Oh God, how
can there be typos. So unprofessional. They
have like, two years. Can't you get the typos
out? I mean, how hard can it be?" Having been
through the process and seeing how tight those
deadlines are and how many different people
look at the book, I can completely see how
it happens.
And I don't have the final copy. I'm not able
to make those final edits. So, at some point,
the book's gotta ship, thankfully. Because
otherwise, I think I'd be writing this book
the rest of my life. So now, I figure it's
a fun game. You can see I don't know how many
post-its are on here. Maybe nine or ten. So
it's like a scavenger hunt. You can see if
you find all the typos.
There's one, even, on the first page. That's
like, even a better good luck sign.
[laughter]
Four. Behold the magic of serendipity. I've
had so much fun with serendipitous meetings
throughout the course of this project. There's
two stories that I wanna share on this point.
One, when I went, so a lot of people don't
know that looking for a literary agent, there
is no science.
There is no magic. It's total chaos. You basically
come up with a query email, little bit about
me, little bit about my project. And you start
going through a directory of 400 names and
you just start emailing people. That's how
it works unless you have personal connections.
I had found four and sometimes people will
email 50 agents and not hear back from any;
I was lucky.
I emailed about ten and I heard back from
four who wanted to work with me. I had a contract
ready to go from this guy in New York, and
we showed it to a family friend, who's a lawyer.
He was looking at the contract and he said,
"This is a little vague. I'm not so sure.
I know a literary agent. How would you feel
if I put you in touch with her?" At that point,
I said, "Sure. Why not?"
So he put me in touch with her. She got back
to me within an hour. I was actually travelling
in Dublin for work at the time. And she said,
"I wanna work with you." Little did I know,
she's a veteran of the industry, she's been
in the business 20 years, used to work for
Rolling Stone, and I ended up going with her.
And that happened solely through this power
of serendipity. My other story is, and this
is a screen shot from the book trailer video
that we did, that's at lacbook.com, if any
of you want to check it out. It was a dream
of mine to have a book trailer video and they
can cost ten, fifteen thousand dollars at
a minimum, to have a professional film and
edit.
So in December, I had just turned in, this
last November, was when the final, final book,
I turned it in and it went to press. And I
thought, "You know, now might be a good time
to leave the house, and maybe even go on a
few dates." So I signed up for OkCupid. I
was like, "Jenny, he's not gonna come out
of your couch or your computer. Leave the
house."
[laughter]
I know, proud of me, right? It's a start.
It's a start. Went on a few online dates.
None of them worked out, but one of the people
that I met turns out to be a four-time, Emmy-winning
movie producer. We decided he had the guts
to say, "I'm just call this one at friends."
We ended up hanging out.
[laughter]
I know, 'cause that's hard to say. We hang
out and he said, "I'd be happy to help you
film your book trailer." So there I was, from
having going on what I call a "failed online
date," it's actually very successful and it
turned out to film and do this amazing book
trailer video.
Three. Forget the marathon mindset. Focus
on sprints and recovery. This is a concept
from Tony Shorts, who, a lot of his principles
are in our Managing Your Energy course. He
says so often, people treat their careers
and their work and their projects like a marathon.
Go, go, go. Wake up.
Spend a huge, long day at the office. Go home.
Work some more and do it again the next day.
We have this marathon mentality that we're
in it for the long haul. And instead, he recommends
focusing on sprints and recovery instead.
Go really hard. It's inevitable. We're gonna
have periods of time where we're really driving
forward and doing those sprints.
But it's imperative that we build in time
for recovery. I know this because I've had
many, what I call, "hot mess hair-pulling"
moments where I've been burnt out, exhausted,
and totally wiped out and unable to do any
work, even if I wanted to. The last one happened
three weeks before the book came out.
I'd been wrapping up at Google and as the
wrapping up at Google and the book stuff was
ramping up higher and higher and higher, and
I'd been working since December around the
clock, nights and weekends every day. And
I was loving it because this is fun for me.
But, I hadn't built in any time for recovery.
So, three weeks ago, it just snuck right up.
I guess at this point, it's more like six
weeks ago. But it snuck up from behind and
just kicked me in the butt. And there I was,
unable to do anything and I was so nervous.
The book was gonna be out three weeks from
when it was all happening and I didn't know
what to do.
And I just felt like this is not good timing.
I'm on the last mile of this marathon and
I don't have time for this. So that's exactly
when you need to make the time. And I'm thankful.
At least I got it out of the way so that now
I can actually enjoy the book being out. So
build in time for recovery. It's so important.
Two. This is my most "woohoo" point. Meet
halfway between hard work and receiving. A
project like this, and it goes for careers
in general, absolutely involves hard work
and commitment and drive and perseverance
and grinding it out, absolutely. And there's
a part of it that's about receiving and just
letting things happen as they will.
As my friend Tara says "lifting the oars."
You can paddle, paddle, paddle so hard, but
sometimes you need to stop, lift the oars,
and let the boat go where it's gonna go. And
that's how I feel about this book. That, yes,
I've been working around the clock to do as
best a job as I can on writing, editing, and
promotion.
But at some point, I'm gonna have to let go
a little bit and let this have a life of its
own and hope that it does.
Finally, take pride in the journey. There
is so much to be said for being on the field,
playing the game, like I said earlier. It
almost doesn't matter what the outcome is.
When I was doing my book signing over the
weekend, I truly felt like this is a top of
the mountain moment.
But I spent two and a half years winding my
way up and around the mountain. And I did
enjoy it while it was happening and that's
so important 'cause why would we do it otherwise?
So really focus on, be proud of yourself for
doing everything you're doing. Take pride
in the journey and know that the more pride
you take in the journey and the more you enjoy
that, the less the outcome actually matters.
I say in the conclusion of the book, "The
fact that you, reader, are holding this in
your hands, that's success alone." My biggest
fear, before I got the book deal, was that
even if I got a book deal, I wouldn't be able
to sell more than two copies, one for each
parent.
[laughter]
Thanks to Books Inc., even just here today,
we have proved that wrong. Thank goodness.
So to me, it wasn't about book sales. It was
that the fact that this physical product exists,
that's plenty and everything else is icing
on the cupcake.
[whispering] The cupcake, yes.
[laughter]
Another quote that I love, "A professional
writer is an amateur who didn't quit."
And that's truly how I feel. There is no magic,
other than these great little serendipitous
moments. I'm not superhuman. I'm not different
than any of you. I just took one step after
another and didn't give up. For as many times
as I wanted to give up, I kept going. And
that's why I'm able to say that I have this
book out today.
So I'm gonna put up my contact information
and I'll tell you a little bit about the book.
It's funny, I gave this talk at my first bookstore
signing last week at Kepler's in Menlo Park
and my mom said, "That was a great speech,
but you didn't tell us about the book." It's
like, you gotta at least tell people what
the book is. So, this is for you, mom.
My book, I wrote this book because I wanted
to write a book that I would like to read.
I am a self-help junkie, self-admitted. I
read almost 200 personal development books
and it started because I took a leave of absence
from UCLA at the start of my junior year and
came home to work full-time at this start-up
company.
I was lost, confused. So I read and I researched
and I looked up information on everything
under the sun: time management, productivity,
personal growth, happiness, leadership. You
name it, I've read it. And after reading all
those books, I wanted to produce something
that was both a guide, but also I call it
a portable life coach.
So there's a chapter for every area of someone's
life, things like work, money, dating and
relationships, friends and family, fitness
and nutrition, organization. And within each
chapter, there are snippets of tips, quotes,
advice from college graduates, coaching exercises,
and recommended reading.
And what I'm noticing in a lot of the Amazon
reviews, people are saying, "This book is
great. Not just for college grads, but anyone."
I've had people all the way up in their 60s
say, "Oh, this arrived for my son and I've
been flipping through and I love it." So my
hope is that you feel free to check it out.
They did a great job.
It's actually bigger than your standard paperback
and there's little red headings and places
to write. So I'm so thrilled with how the
book actually came out. And my goal was, it's
basically to say you're the expert on your
life. I trust that you're all smart and resourceful.
You know how to Google things like 401K and
filing your taxes.
I didn't want to bother anyone with that.
Instead, my goal was to share my own tips,
nuggets from other people, and then really
put the power in your hands to focus on the
big picture of your life. To think about,
it's a self-help book. I had to give it some
audacious title like, "The Complete Guide
to Getting What You Want."
It's a perfect infomercial and ready to go.
But truly, the reason I say that it's complete
is because I'm gonna help you facilitate a
process where you can think and vision and
dream for every area of your life. One of
the things that I've noticed most as a coach,
and the receiving end of many coaching sessions,
is that it's very rare.
We don't often ask each other, what do you
really want? Tell me what your dream home
looks like. It's not common for us to envision
the highest goals that we have and the highest
vision for our lives. And so, my hope is to
help facilitate that process for people and
to give a book where you can dive in at any
point and come back and revisit it, over and
over again.
That's all I got, so thank you so much. And
I'll take questions. There's a mic over here
if you have questions.
[applause]
All right, don't be shy.
>>Female Audience Member #1: Do we have to
go to the mic?
>>Jenny Blake: I'll repeat the question. Go
ahead.
>>Female Audience Member #1: Well actually,
I was gonna share a serendipitous story, 'cause--
>>Jenny Blake: Oh, thanks.
>>Female Audience Member #1: last week, a
friend of mine that I met through a mutual
friend emailed me and said, "Hey, Phil told
me that you were interested in meeting my
life coach, Jenny." And the girl's name is
Christy [inaudible]. So actually you know
I was coming here today with my friends
>>Jenny Blake: Oh, my gosh.
>>Female Audience Member #1: and people were
like let's go see this talk and so, I looked
back in my email and I was like, "Is this
the same person?" And it was, so it was just
really cool.
>>Jenny Blake: That's so cool.
>>Female Audience Member #1: And I didn't
realize that's what was going on, so, serendipitous
story.
>>Jenny Blake: That's very cool. And on that
note, Christy was one of my earliest blog
readers, when it was just my parents and Christy.
[laughter]
And so, she has stuck around for over three
and a half years now. And we first met in
person at South by Southwest last year in
Austin, Texas. So, amazing, nice to meet you.
Thank you for coming.
>>Female Audience Member #1: [ inaudible]
>>Jenny Blake: That's so cool. I love it.
I love it. Other questions? Fun stories?
>>Female Audience Member #2: We can use the
mic so [inaudible].
>>Jenny Blake: Yeah. And then use the mic
for people on VC and the recording. Neat?
Do you wanna go to the mic?
>>Female Audience Member #3: [inaudible].
>>Jenny Blake: OK. It's just time to make
you do some work. I'm here holding this thing
all day. OK.
>>Female Audience Member #3: So I know you've
had a major sprint and you're taking a little
rest now, but do you have any plans for a
second book?
>>Jenny Blake: Haha.
[laughter]
Plans for a second book. Truly, I think people
have said, "Oh, it's like having a baby. You
have to forget the pain involved in order
to do it again." That's probably gonna be
true. I have, gears are turning for a second
book. Yes. And I don't know exactly what it'll
be, but I know I have one in me. And having
been through the process now, I at least feel
like, at least I'll mostly be tackling the
big ideas and less of the how’s. So yeah,
thanks for asking. But until then, I'm taking
a little break. Hi.
>>Female Audience Member #4: I'm Tara.
>>Jenny Blake: Tara of "lift the oars." Wisdom
of greatness.
>>Tara: I'm "life the oars" lady and I actually
stole that from Oprah and Byron Gates.
>>Jenny Blake: OK, great. We're in the presence
of greatness.
>>Tara: [inaudible], I'm not, I'm a junkie
just like Jenny. I would like to say, what's
your most memorable piece of feedback you've
gotten from the book so far?
>>Jenny Blake: Oh, that's such a great question.
OK, the most memorable piece of feedback.
Last night. Last night I couldn't sleep. I
think 'cause I was so excited to see all you
guys. It was about 2 am and someone tweeted
and they said, "Jenny, I just picked up your
book. I've read ten pages in and I can already
tell it's gonna change my life."
And it just, it's so touching and so inspiring.
That's exactly why I did this. That's what
makes the entire journey worth it that people
say things like that. And to be able to have
that kind of impact on one person, let alone
multiple, is completely humbling for me and
totally amazing.
So, it's moments like that and there are many
more where that came from, but that's the
first one that comes to mind. That someone
I've never met, on Twitter, who I didn't pay
to be my friend is saying that this book is
already changing her life and that she's only
ten pages in. I am, it's beyond my wildest
dreams to be able to have that kind of impact
with this book. So, thank you. Great question.
Yeah. Great. Keep 'em coming.
>>Female Audience Member #3: So how did you
find that tweet?
>>Jenny Blake: Oh, this is from a great question
of how did I find that tweet. Well, I was
on my Google Android and I used a Twitter
program that shows me my @replies.
>>Female Audience Member #3: OK.
>>Jenny Blake: Yeah.
>>Female Audience Member #3: [inaudible].
>>Jenny Blake: Yes. Hi Steve.
>>Steve: Hi. You talked about a lot of different
sections of the book and advice to give to
different parts of life. Which one of those
was the hardest for you to write or did you
learn the most or you grew through writing
the most?
>>Jenny Blake: Yeah. Love this question. Well,
it will not be a surprise to anyone who knows
me; the hardest chapter to write, hands down,
dating and relationships.
[laughter]
Cue endless laughter. All right. The point
is, and I said this, I talked to a group of
new grads earlier this morning. A big project
involves trade-offs. And my trade-off has
been working full-time at Google and then
nights and weekends on my projects, for the
most part.
Of course, I do leave the house from time
to time. I'm not a total hermit. But, dating
and relationships, I hadn't over the last
three years. I hadn't been in any significant
relationships where it was like a serious,
committed thing. And so, I was drawing upon
my own wisdom, some dating experiences. It
wasn't just my own personal challenge.
It was that of all chapters, people are in
such different places after college in terms
of dating and relationships. Some are single
and loving it; single and hating it; dating
casuall; in a relationship; engaged; married;
divorced. And my question was, how can I possibly
write a chapter and I have bitten off a lot
with this book talking about every area of
someone's life for all of after-college, like
I had my hands full as it was.
How do I provide tips and exercises that aren't
totally cliché, that add value, and that
are gonna work across the board? And that
was a big challenge for me. Thankfully, I
had enough cobbled together and one person
actually told me this was their favorite chapter.
So, something I did worked, which is good.
And one of the most popular exercises that
I had posted on my blog is a break-up processing
template. Yes.
[laughter]
I'm famous, infamous, for templatizing everything.
You'll be proud to know it's in Google Docs
in Spreadsheets. And it's a template. If you're
breaking up with someone and it walks you
through some ways to process. So anyway, I
think that, yeah, people get a lot out of
that. Check it out.
There's also decision-making, budgeting. I
have lots of other templates, but that's one
of my favorites. Any other questions? All
right.
>>Male Audience Member #5: Hello, Jenny.
>>Jenny Blake: Hi.
>>Male Audience Member #5: What is your favorite
kind of cupcake?
>>Jenny Blake: Oh. I love it. I'm so glad
you asked. This is a very important question.
What is my favorite kind of cupcake? Red velvet
is my benchmark cupcake in that, if I go to
a cupcake shop, I always have to have the
red velvet to assess where that cupcake shop
falls among all others that I've been to.
And then I also like to try whatever might
be unique to that cupcake place.
So, vanilla with sprinkles, blueberry crumb
cake. I once had a cupcake with glitter on
it, actual glitter. That was at Delish in
Austin, Texas. So I would say red velvet,
definitely. And then if you go to Sprinkles,
their vanilla cupcake is also divine. Or,
Crumbs in New York, their cupcakes are the
size of your head with like, every candy from
the shelf just shoved on top; delicious.
[pause]
And by the way, cupcakes are one of my values
that are in the book in the Life chapter,
under my list of personal values. Cupcakes:
fun, celebration, indulgence. We should all
have more cupcakes in our lives. I think that's
a great place to end. Thank you all so much
for being here. I'm gonna sign books in the
back.
[applause]
Thank you. Thanks.